what's going on people the attack on
titan anime is finally back and in this
video i'll be breaking down episode 17
of the final season when the first half
of the season ended last year things
left off with zeke being blown to pieces
by thunderspear while the malian army
began their surprise attack on
shiganchena and today's episode begins
only minutes after this
as usual i'll be answering all the
important questions like how exactly
zeke was saved and why eren's true
motivations might not be what it seems
before we get into it though i'd really
appreciate if you smash that sub button
for more attack on titan videos like
this as i'll be reviewing every episode
as the season goes on not to mention i'm
planning a bunch of other stuff as well
okay so starting things off with zeke's
resurrection for a bit of context the
last time we saw him he was less than
half a person and basically on the brink
of death but he was then approached by
one of the pure titans he'd created
earlier it then proceeded to shove zeke
inside his stomach and what essentially
happened after this was that this pure
titan used its own flesh to rebuild his
body
that's why in the opening scene of
episode 17 a fully formed butt naked
zeke emerges while the titan itself is
reduced to bones after seemingly
fulfilling its purpose
the way the light breaks through the
cards when he's reborn was a really nice
touch and the whole opening scene in
general just had a really cinematic feel
that being said the real mystery here is
why would a titan sacrifice itself to
save a human because historically
speaking this is literally the opposite
of what they do
to answer this question it's important
to first remember that before zeke was
about to die he saw a vision of a young
girl and in this episode he mentions
that it was her who sculpted his body in
the past dimension the past dimension is
a place that exists outside of our
normal reality and in the past we've
seen the eldians can go there in
particular circumstances
these paths that we see in the sky are
the things that connect every single ld
into the founding titan and in zeke's
case since he has real blood his
connection to the founder is more
special than other aldians for that
reason the girl chose to save him
specifically because he has royal blood
and as the season continues his
connection to her will be explained in
greater detail but for now this is all
we need to know
when it comes to the situation with the
jaegerus in the previous episode hanji
was being forced to take them to zeke's
location but after hearing the sound of
a thunderspear flock decided to change
directions so they could investigate
this is how the yageras were able to
find levi and zeke in his open field and
after being hit with a thunder spirit
close range the captain was undeniably
in the worst shape of his life
besides the fact that he was
unresponsive and covered in blood he had
also lost two fingers that were still
attached to the trigger of his equipment
what was interesting about this scene is
just how much the jaegers wanted to make
sure he was dead cause until this moment
they assumed that the captain would try
to stop them from bringing zeke back to
shiganchina and you know what if he was
conscious he probably would have this is
the reason why hanji tried to claim that
levi was dead so that maybe they'd leave
him alone but one zeke emerged she had
no choice but to try and escape to put
it simply there's no way the beast titan
would have allowed his greatest enemy
who's defeated him you know two or three
times now there's no way he could have
allowed him to survive so by hanji
jumping into the river with the captain
it at least gives him some chance of
staying alive
now switching over to mali's surprise
attack on shigachina at the start of the
episode the malians had two main
objectives the first objective was for
either rhino or poco to eat the founding
titan while pique was meant to provide
support with this special anti-titan
cannon the cannon was dropped into the
district as soon as the invasion began
and in this screenshot you can see that
she saw it coming from a distance which
is how peak knew exactly where she
needed to go unfortunately at this time
she'd been handcuffed to gabby so she
wasn't immediately able to transform
since her titan explosion would have
likely killed the warrior candidate
that's why the draw titan had to sever
off her hand so that these two could be
separated and in the process the card
titan was then able to manifest
one small piece of trivia to mention is
that in the very first episode of the
season you'll remember that these
anti-tank cannons were actually
developed by the middle eastern alliance
and molly just stole them after winning
the war hence why it's now been modified
to fit the cart titan
anyway general mcgath's secondary
objective was to rescue gabby and falco
and his reaction to seeing gabby again
was very emotional for amalian
especially considering this is the same
guy who sent hundreds if not thousands
of eldians to their deaths i mean in the
first episode he was literally about to
sacrifice 800 of them
when it comes to falco's location he was
still locked up in a prison cell along
with the other soldiers who drank zeke
spawn of fluid and it was now cult's
responsibility to go and find his
younger brother
just before we move on to eren's fight
with reiner it's worth pointing out that
for the first time ever marley finally
realized that zeke might be a titan of
royal blood after gabby remembered what
he said on the airship this means that
on top of everything else their new
objective is also to stop zeke from
making contact with aaron
in terms of what aaron himself was
thinking early in the episode he was
just surprised that marley was able to
launch a counter-attack so soon given
that he had wiped out all of their top
military officials despite that it was
thanks to reina's persistence that
marley went ahead with this invasion
only one month later and it didn't take
aaron long to realize he was responsible
the armored titan then parachutes into
the city which was reminiscent of what
he did at forslava only this time around
he's also joined by hundreds of other
malian soldiers
during that fight the anime definitely
answered the question of who has the
better titan hardening cause rhino
literally tried to break through aaron's
defenses over 10 times with no success
only for aaron to then just break
through his armor in one punch i just
think they need to come up with a brand
new name for this shifter because it
seems like the armor crumbles every
single time he's in a real contest
in any case with rhino on the ground
galia tried to sneak up on the attack
titan in a moment that parallels what he
did in liberia and as he went in for the
kill we got to see aaron's war hammer
titan abilities his first move was to
create huge spikes of titan hardening
that were literally coming out of his
actual body which is a way we've not
exactly seen his power used before
regardless of that galliard quickly
swiped it all away because the draw
titan is essentially the natural enemy
of the warhammer as the fight continued
eren was backed into a corner where he
had to use more substantial amounts of
hardening to defend himself and in
fairness he was able to push back the
two warriors with reiner looking
especially messed up
the slight downside with this game plan
is that the warhammer's abilities do
drain energy pretty quickly as we saw
with lara tiber so it's usually a smart
move not to overdo it
anyhow with reiner and galliard
suspended in the air mcgath provides him
with the assist by firing through the
founding titan's brain by doing this
aaron needs time to regenerate before
his titan can move again giving the
warriors an opening to break free it
should be pointed out that if the
general wanted to he could have actually
killed him there by going for the name
but it's always been mega's philosophy
that killing aaron would only postpone
the problem because if aaron died then
the power of his founding titan would be
inherited by a newborn aldian child this
is why he's relying on one of the
warriors to eat him instead so that
marley can guarantee they'll never have
to deal with this problem again
meanwhile focusing on the volunteers for
a second these guys were horrified at
the way things were developing but for
two very different reasons in yellow in
this case she needs aaron to survive so
that zeke's dream of euthanizing the
aldean race can still happen as a result
she sent a ton of soldiers to protect
him but sadly they were easily being
overwhelmed by the machine guns on
marley's airships not to mention all the
malian soldiers on the rooftops
when it comes to onyankapon now his
motivation for saving aaron has nothing
to do with the euthanization plan
because what he wanted was for the
yeager brothers to destroy mali as
revenge for what they did to his home
country that's why in this scene he runs
down to the jail cells to try and get
some reinforcements because the battle
right now was definitely not looking in
their favor
in this moment here we got a nice shot
of poco maneuvering through the
warhammer titan spikes and if you slow
this moment down you can see the camera
literally goes through the hole in his
chest which i thought was pretty cool
following this the alden soldiers
continue to be massacred left and right
while the founding titan itself is shot
in the head for a second time
because the general kept on aiming for
the brain aaron was temporarily
paralyzed again giving reiner the chance
to stab him with a shard of his own
titan hardening
in this particular scene magath
references a moment earlier in the
season when wheelie tiger said that
marley needed another hero and the way
this scene is set up is implied that
that hero could in fact be reiner this
is funny considering that reiner's early
motivations back in the day was to be a
hero that could save the world and now
after a lot of mistakes he's now
stumbled into a position where he can
seemingly still achieve that goal
now moving down to the prison cells
onyankapon wanted to release armin
mikasa and the other prisoners so they
could lend their strength to try and
save eren in previous seasons it would
have been almost guaranteed that they'd
agreed to help but connie and drawn
rightly point out that helping aaron
also means helping with zeke's
euthanization plan
i explained this in my review of the
first half of the season but basically
aaron agreed to help zeke peacefully end
the aldian race by using his founding
titan to remove their ability to
reproduce that philosophy is not
something anyone in this room would
really want to risk their lives for so
you can understand why they'd be
skeptical in helping out however in this
episode armin comes to the realization
that maybe aaron doesn't actually
believe in this kind of euthanization
and he's just pretending to follow zeke
and yell in his plan
after all way back in season one when we
got to see inside aaron's mind he said
the reason he wanted to explore the
outside and acquire freedom is because
he was born into this world so why would
he then want to stop future generations
from being born it doesn't make sense
that he would spend years fighting for
freedom only to then deny that same
freedom to future aldians so armin does
make a good point that maybe aaron is
just playing along
if the two brothers make contact then
it's ultimately aaron's decision how the
founding titan will be used meaning that
he doesn't really have to follow the
euthanization plan if he doesn't want to
what ahmed is essentially saying here is
that they need to take a chance to save
aaron and just hope that he's really on
their side
on a separate note he also theorizes
that the idea of mikasiv being
controlled by her ackman dna is another
lie that eren made up although in this
case he doesn't provide an explanation
as to why he thinks it's not true all we
know is that in the last episode it was
suggested that there might be a hidden
motive behind why he said these things
but for now that's all we got
anyway the episode ends with elder
soldiers still getting destroyed on the
surface and i gotta say the anime has
really elevated the level of like
graphic-ness and bloodiness of this
conflict because in the manga we legit
didn't see anywhere close to this number
of soldiers being killed
with that said that was my breakdown for
episode 17 of attack on time season four
and it's been many many months since my
last review so i'd appreciate if you
dropped a like hit that sub button if
you haven't already and let me know in
the comments what you thought of the
episode
until the next one peace out